As far as I know, we're picking up in June the 23rd, 1906, okay?
Louisa said, "continuing to feel ill, I told the confessor what I have written above.
Keeping silent about a few things regarding the same topic, partly because of the extreme
weakness I felt as I had no strength to speak and partly out of fear that obedience might
set some trap from me, okay? Oh, holy God, what fear?" She said, "God alone knows how I live.
I live dying continuously and my only relief would be dying to find my life again in God."
So the only relief would be to die physically and go to God. Yet obedience wants to act as a cruel
executioner, keeping me dying continuously rather than living forever in God. So she has no permission
to die. Do you remember that? A few volumes back. All obedience, how terrible and strong you are.
So the confessor who gives the obedience told me that he would not permit it and that I was to
tell the Lord that obedience didn't want what a most bitter pain. So finding myself in my usual
state, I saw our Lord and the confessor praying him not to let me die. That's the issue, she's not
allowed to die. Fearing that he might listen to him, I was crying and the Lord told me, "Daughter
because do not afflict me with your crying." How many husbands have ever said that? "I have every
reason to take you because I want to scourge the world and out of regard for you and your sufferings
I feel though bound. But the confessor is also right in wanting to keep you on the earth because
poor world and poor corrato in the station which it finds itself, what would happen to it if there
was no one to protect it?" Now at this particular point, Louisa is not really ready to consider the
fact that the world will disintegrate if it doesn't have victim souls. So I keep asking people that
if you find that there are victim souls for the 20th century, I will be consoled otherwise there's
only chastisement because that's what Jesus has told Louisa many times, okay? Now for that whole
text with Louisa wanting to die and having to stay, it's 2 Corinthians 5, 1 to 10. 2 Corinthians 5,
1 to 10. So we're coming to this new point now that Jesus says, "If I take you to heaven,
then there's nobody to defend the earth, there's nobody to make reparation and therefore justice
will have its way." That means it'll be terrible. So that's what he means by it, there's no one to
protect it. And also for himself that's the priest because since you are there, I make use of you
sometimes directly saying something regarding him and sometimes indirectly reprimanding him,
pushing him and keeping him from doing something that may displease me.
Now there you have one of the mysteries of spiritual direction. It's the priest who is directing her
and here's the Lord saying that he is directing the priest through her. Now we have many examples
of that in the church. Can you think of any? I'll start you off. Saint Catherine of Siena
and Father Raymond of Capua. He was eventually made venerable. I don't think he was ever canonized.
Mary and Claude at Columbia. Margaret, Mary, Alacoke isn't it? Yeah, let me write that down.
Hang on, Mary, A-L-A, whatever. Claude, it's okay. Now you've done it across the trees of Avela,
okay? Francis of Sissy and Claire. Francis of Sissy and Claire. Francis DeSales and
Jane DeChantal, okay. That's a lot just in a moment, isn't it? That means there's lots more.
And what happens is, you know, the priest is directing the woman and yet the Lord is using
the woman to direct the priest. Okay, so Faustina and her spiritual directors, yeah. But the thing
is that the Lord works at both ends of the line. The Lord is not letting the priest,
say you're the priest, the Lord is not letting the priest give life one way and for the priest not
to benefit because the Lord loves each of them equally. So while he on the part of the church
is directing the woman, the Lord is using the woman to direct him. Whether she's conscious of it or not
is another matter. Sometimes they're conscious of it and sometimes they're not. And here's Jesus
telling Louisa who wasn't all that conscious of it. This is what I do as well. So the priest would
be without you helping him to get to a higher place because the priest is going to learn about
divine will through Louisa. There's no other way to learn it, is there? Okay. So for someone
protecting the humanity against destruction, I want to give you Sam 106 verse 23. Sam 106 verse 23,
that is Moses stood in the breach to protect the people. Sam 58 12, Sam 58 12, and lamentations
213. I think there's also one in Isaiah that I can't remember at this moment lamenting that there
was nobody to stand in the breach. You know, to stand in the breach means that you're standing
between divine justice and the sinfulness of the people and that you're taking on the
reparation to satisfy divine justice so that mercy and more time will be given to the sinners to repent.
Okay. So Jesus said, "If I call you to myself, I will make use of his sufferings, but courage,
as things are now, I feel more disposed to make you content rather than the confessor,
and I myself will know how to change the will." Okay. And then Louisa, then Louisa said, "I found
myself inside of myself without having told him that obedience didn't want it. It did not seem
necessary for me to say it, since I had seen the confessor together with the Lord and it seemed
to me that he already knew everything." Well, naturally, if she sees, the beauty of it is that she
frequently saw her confessor in the spiritual realm with Jesus and the three of them could have a dialogue.
So June the 24th, 1906, she's still wanting to go to heaven. One of the extraordinary traits
of Louisa Picaretta was this very painful need to see God forever. And the reason for that was
that she had seen him now. And one of the reasons why the Lord doesn't allow us to see him, that we
have to walk by faith and not by sight, is because all of the saints say that if you see him,
you want to be with him forever. And ecstasy means, of course, that the soul goes out of itself
to try and reach the Lord. And if you go out of yourself forever, then it's death. And this is the
reason for this very painful experience that Louisa has, that she's on the earth and wants to be in
heaven. And we can have the opposite with many people that they're dying and they don't want to
leave the earth. And that's because they haven't had a decent experience of God. So they don't realize
what's coming. So after I told the confessor what is written above, he got upset, for he absolutely
wanted me to oppose the Lord because obedience didn't want to. As for myself, I was feeling worse.
As the thought of the many privations of blessed Jesus, which had burned me to the quick over and
over again, made me long for heaven. I felt my poor humanity vividly. And it kept grumbling
against obedience. Now look at the way she's able to separate my humanity and my will.
In other words, the poor old body wanted something, but I was determined to do God's will. Okay.
I felt my poor humanity as if it was under a press that's Isaiah 63, 3. Isaiah 63, 3.
And I couldn't make up my mind. In the meantime, our Lord came with an art of light in his hands.
A side came out also of light, which touched the art that blessed Jesus held in his hands. And as
the arch was touched, it remained absorbed in Christ. And he disappeared without giving me the time
to tell him what obedience wanted. Now the wonderful thing, well, there's so many wonderful
things about this woman. She has just received a revelation from the Lord about this arch and
the light. And the only thing she says is, oh, but he didn't give me time to tell him about the
obedience. And so instead of that, we would have expected her to say the arch means this and the
light means that this is what the Lord was saying. She doesn't do that. Which tells you this is a
very authentic relationship, isn't it? I understood that the arch was my soul and the side was dead.
She gives you just as a dead pan in the end. So June the 26th, 1906, continuing the same way,
the confessor came and he kept giving me the same obedience that she had not to die.
Then as baby Jesus came, I told him of my bitterness. We don't say bitterness. S,
that's not English regarding the obedience. And he caressed me. We would say,
sympathized with me, compassionate of me is not a word we use, is it? And gave me many kisses. Now,
why would you do that? Because he's coming as an infant. And so I want you to notice that many times
in these writings, but not beyond Volume 20. She's in a different world in Volume 20,
or totally. I mean, you'll realize when you get a Volume 20 that you've shifted from a 747 into a
rocket that takes you onto the next level completely. It's almost breathtaking the jump you get from
19 to 20. But up to that, whenever she sees Jesus, he comes to her when she's suffering,
so that he allows her feminine nature to express itself. He allows her motherliness to reach out
to an infant, hug an infant, and kiss the infant, and be kissed by the infant. And that actually
comforts her. I find that very, very interesting. If Louisa was a man, the Lord would comfort him in
whatever way a manly person needed, which would be quite different. But he allows her this motherly
thing every now and then. I find it fascinating. Okay. So through these kisses, he infused a breath
of life into me. Now, the breath of life is the Holy Spirit. Ruach Adonai is the correct words in
Hebrew or U-A-C-H and A-D-O-N-A-I. Ruach Adonai. That's the breath of life. Now, when you go to
Genesis 27, when God breathed the breath of life into Adam, he became a living being, you remember?
And living being meant that he was spiritually alive. So he infused a breath of life into me,
and I found myself inside myself. I felt my humanity as though strengthened. God alone can
understand these pains of mine because there are pains that I am unable to narrate. And he has
already said there pains like purgatory or hell. I hope at least that the Lord may want to give light
to those who give these kinds of obedience. In other words, that they shouldn't be doing it.
May the Lord forgive me. The pain makes me speak even two excess, we would say.
You'd have to put two excess. So July the 2nd, 1906, as I was in my usual state and my sufferings
kept increasing a little. Blessed Jesus came for just a little, and he told me, "My daughter,
truly, I want to take you because I want to disengage myself from the world." Now, the bit you need
to underline is disengage myself from the world. That is the disaster. Because if you read Romans
chapter 1, the whole chapter, you'll be told three times, that is why God abandoned them. God abandoned
them to their terrible lusts, God abandoned them to their unnatural sins, God abandoned them to
their wickedness. God abandoning us is the worst punishment of all. Okay? So they've already had
the conversation, as we read a few minutes ago, that if Louisa dies and goes to heaven,
then the world is in real trouble. So now he's testing her to see where she is on this whole thing,
and so he says, "Yeah, I'll take you, and I'll disengage from the world." It seemed he wanted to
tempt me. That word should be changed to test. He wanted to test me, but I did not say anything
about he is taking me because obedience was opposed, and also because I'm sorry for the world.
Now, can you see what's going on? He is trying to get her to find another reason to stay,
and that's why I give you that two Corinthians 5, 1 to 10, because Saint Paul wanted to die and
to be with the Lord, but he said that out of consideration for the needs of the people he would
stay, so he decided to stay for a love of neighbor. So this is what the Lord is trying to pull out of
Louisa. It doesn't mean she doesn't love the neighbor, but he's trying to get her to make that
decision at a very painful point. So she said, "I'm sorry for the world." In the meantime,
he showed me his hand, and he had a most beautiful ring with a white gem on his finger,
and many little gold rings were hanging from this gem, and they were intertwined and formed
a beautiful ornament for the hand of our Lord. You don't normally get Jesus described as wearing
rings. And all these visions that she sees, they're all symbolic of something. He kept showing it.
So much did he like it, and he said, "You've done this for me in the past days by means of your
sufferings, and I'm preparing a more beautiful one for you." So he's trying to say, "This is the
fruit of your labor, that you have done something beautiful for God, if I can quote who?" Maria Theresa
of Calcutta. Okay. "That you've done more than you realize." Now, as you go on in the volumes,
he will explain to Louisa more and more what the suffering of his privation is doing for her,
because I've explained to you before, Louisa was prepared to carry the crown of thorns,
she was prepared to be crucified, but she didn't want this suffering. And the definition of your
cross is not the bits you're willing to take, but the bit that you find unenjoyable. And she
couldn't see it that this was her cross, and he's getting her more and more to use it and to do
great things. So obviously, if there's a big ring and there's little rings, that a lot has been
accomplished. So July the 3rd, this 1906 is a very important one put a VIP on it. The will of God
is the paradise of the soul on earth. Now, this is going to be elaborated on hugely in the higher
volumes. And the soul who does the will of God forms the paradise of God on the earth.
Now, notice the term paradise. We are inclined to say that the Garden of Eden was paradise.
And this is something you can discuss later. You can, I'm just going to give you a little bit,
and you can draw it out later on. And it wasn't paradise because of all the plants.
And all the animals. And it wasn't paradise because Adam and Eve just happened to be there.
It was paradise because of the relationship that Adam and Eve had with God and with each other.
Does that make sense? Because when we are happy in a marriage relationship, we say it's heaven.
If we're all happy in a marriage relationship, we say it's hell. They're actually very good
symbols to use. They're actually correct because the paradise is in the relationship.
And as we go forward in these volumes, Jesus is going to give an enormous amount of material
on the fall of Adam. And what it was like beforehand, and what it was like afterwards,
beforehand, it was heaven afterwards, it was hell. And it wasn't just hell for Adam and Eve. It was
hell for the animals and the plants and for the earth and for absolutely everything. To the point
where Romans 819 says that the whole of creation is crying out for the sons of God to show themselves.
And Jesus says that those sons of God are the ones in the divine will. Because only they can
bring back the harmony between God and creation, God and human beings. Okay. So the image of
paradise is actually the image of union with God in love and union with your neighbor in love as well.
So if you have an idea of how to use the word paradise, then the text is going to make more
sense to you. Is that okay? So having received communion, I felt all united and classed to my
most divine Jesus. While he classed me, I rested in him and he rested in me. Then he told me,
my beloved, the soul who lives in my will rests. Now to rest doesn't mean to do nothing.
It means that you're not agitated, you're not stressed out, you're not filled with anxiety,
you're not disturbed. That rest is one of the great things that the Bible speaks about. Okay.
So to introduce the word rest, I want to give you Matthew 1128 to 30. Okay. Come to me and you
will find rest, didn't you say that? You'll find rest for your soul. I want to give you,
so that's Matthew 1128 to 30. I want to give you Hebrews 4, 1 to 11, where the author says,
we can still find the rest that the Hebrew people failed to get because of their rebellion against
God. Now notice rebellion against God, you go out of rest and into anxiety and into all kinds of
problems. When you eventually come in to the divine will, notice I'm using the word eventually,
because we're in the divine will, but if you're in a 24, 7, 3, 6, 5, you have the rest.
And one of the keys to understanding how you are developing in divine will is that the peace
that you experience, and you have that because you're in grace and you're in relationship with
God and you're doing God's will to the best of your ability. You have that grace and you have
the peace, but the peace goes deeper and deeper and deeper and deeper until it passes all understanding.
Philippians 4, 7, and it guards your heart and your mind in Christ Jesus. It actually becomes
your protector. Okay. So this rest is actually terribly important. In order to travel towards
that rest, you need Sam 61, where you're told several times in the Sam rest in God, my soul,
rest in God, my soul. Okay. But the one who has found rest is Sam 131. My soul is like a weaned
child on its mother's lap. That child has found rest, hasn't it? Sam 131. It's very short, Sam.
One, three. My soul is like a weaned child on its mother's lap. Okay. And I want to give you Sam 37,
and Sam 1167. So something that the Wednesday class has come to sort of realize is that the
next level of study after you've done the major themes is to pick up something like rest
and find out what is what everything the Lord says about it in these writings. It'll be completely
new way. And on Wednesday night, they had, well, I think they had seven or eight words that really
need to be followed. So here's one of the big ones, rest. Okay. And Jesus says you find that rest
ultimately by living completely in the divine will. Okay. Now my beloved, the soul who lives
in my will, that means that you're really living in the divine will and rests because the divine
will does everything for her. Do you remember you desire it? I'll do it. You remember? Okay. And while
it operates for her, I find the most beautiful rest in her. Okay. So the will of God is rest for
the soul and rest for God in the soul, because that soul is not battling him. That soul is allowing
him to reign in her. And it's always her for the soul. Okay. We dealt with that, didn't we?
Because the soul is the receiver and he's the giver. And so while resting in my will,
the soul remains always attached to my mouth. Now to my mouth, you would get his word, his teaching.
Okay. And suckles divine life into ourselves, making of it or continuous food. So as we go along,
he will tell us that if we want to persevere in divine will, we have to persevere in studying
the books, because that's us having our mouth to his ear to receive everything.
The will of God is the paradise of the soul on earth. And the soul who does the will of God
comes to form the paradise of God on earth. I want to give you a Proverbs 831 there. Proverbs
831. God delights to be with the children of men. Now, what is said there? You will come to
understand much more fully when he begins to explain Adam before the fall and Adam after the fall.
The expression he himself uses is Adam innocent and Adam fallen. And so when the person is living
in the divine will not only can you rest in God, but that you become the place where God rests on
the earth. And the Lord is in the process of trying to return to the earth as we speak.
And he's doing it through every single person who is trying to live in the divine will that
we give him a place on the earth where he can rest and he can work from there. And an example
of that is he has said that if a person does the hours of the passion in the divine will only,
you can do the hours of the passion at a human level. But that's not what we're talking about.
If you do the hours of the passion at a divine level, not only will he save a soul
for every word that you actually do, but everybody in your area is blessed. You allow him to reach
out from you to them. You see what it means to have him resting in a soul that every single person
in the earth, I often think of that when I'm sitting here and I say, everybody in celebrity and
league slip and Luke and all their around the place, they're all blessed just because I'm doing
this and they'll never know until they go to God. It's just brilliant. And so when you have people
all over the country doing this, then can you see him reaching out to everybody and he's reaching
out silently, which is the way he likes doing it, and he's reaching out very gently because we're
doing the reparation, we're doing the substitution. And so because of that, then he's able to get
around them to come around and come back to him. And so it's an evangelizing ministry where your
audience doesn't travel. They don't leave what they're doing and you go and you meet them where
they're at. That's what Jesus did in the incarnation. He came from heaven to earth and because he was
incarnate, he traveled to everybody, found them wherever they were and helped them in that situation.
He's getting us to do that now at the level of the spirit. It's brilliant, isn't it? But do realize
it's a whole mission that we're actually involved in. So watch this now, and you need to put a big
NB or VIP or green, white and gold colors or something on the next bit. The will of God is the
only key that opens the treasures of the divine secrets. There's no other key. So what I do is
write key in the margin key. And as you go through these early volumes up to volume 11, you'll get a
number of keys. And that's another thing that needs to be studied by itself. What are the keys
to divine will? The will of God is the only key that opens the treasures of the divine secrets and
the soul acquires such familiarity in the house of God as to dominate it as if she was the owner.
Isn't that something else? So there's one of the keys for you. Louisa said, "Who can say what I
understood about the divine will? Oh, the will of God, how admirable, lovable, desirable, beautiful
you are, but you still can't say it. It's going to take up to the later volumes to be able to say it."
It's enough to say that being in you, I feel all my miseries and all my evils being dissolved,
would that be brilliant? And I acquire a new being, notice a new creation, a new being,
with the fullness of all the divine gods. So the two references I want to give you for the new
creation is 2 Corinthians 5, 17, 2 Corinthians 5, 17, and Galatians 6, 15. You become a whole new
creature in Christ. Now in the higher volumes, the Lord will explain that for somebody who actually does
succeed in living the divine will 24, 7, 3, 6, 5, that as far as he's concerned, it's a new baptism.
You begin a completely new life and you become one of the family. The baptism in water and the
spirit that we've already received made you an adopted child of God, but he said that the baptism
into the divine will makes you the actual child of God, which is a different matter all together,
isn't it? So July the 8th, 1906, the soul is drawn by the light of Jesus, where obedience doesn't
want it. So this is part of Louisa's struggle we're talking about here. It continues almost in the
same way. I only feel a little bit more strength. May God be always blessed. Everything is little
in the face of his love, even the very privation. Look at that. This is the first time she's able
to put it in perspective, even being away from heaven and only to obey. Now obedience wants me to
write something about the light which I see from time to time. Sometimes I seem to see our Lord
inside of me and another image, all of light coming out of his humanity. Okay? So she seems to see a
glorified image. He's all of light. More and more of his humanity ignites the fire and the image of
the light of Christ as if it were riddling this fire. And from this riddled fire, a light comes out
fully similar to his image of light. He's all pleased and waits anxiously to unite it to himself.
Then it becomes incorporated once again into his humanity. Other times I find myself outside of
myself and I see myself all fire. Matthew 3. What's the verses? John the Baptist said he will baptize
you with the Holy Spirit and fire. Do you remember? But it's Matthew 3. He will baptize you when
the Holy Spirit and fire. She said I see myself all fire and that's the fire of divine love.
I see the light which is about to take off from the fire. Now notice I see myself. She sees this
image of Jesus. Doesn't explain it. And then all of a sudden she said I see myself all fire. Now
St. Therese of this you also said that she experienced real fire, fire that burns inside of her. Okay?
And then I see the light which is about to take off from the fire and our Lord blowing his breath,
the breath, the spirit into that light. The light rises and begins its way towards the mouth of
Jesus and with his breath he rejects it and attracts it. So that's the positive and negative.
He enlarges it and makes it more shining. Okay? So he's working on it and the poor light
regals about and makes every effort for it wants to go into his mouth. In other words be incorporated
into Christ. Okay? It seems to me that if I arrived at that I would breathe my last. That's why she
wants it. Yet I am forced to say in my interior obedience doesn't want it. In spite of the fact
that saying this costs me my life, who is God, the Lord seems to delight in playing games with this
light. Now you have to analyze that and see what he's saying but the best thing to do is to finish
the message first. It also seems to me that the Lord comes and wants to review everything that
he himself has given me, whether everything is orderly and clean of dust. Now beside all of this
I think you need to put Philippians 1-6. The work he has begun in you he will finish. Okay?
Because many of us don't have the concept of the Lord actually working in us. Some people do.
So you want to see whether everything was orderly. Why would he be looking for everything being
orderly? If you go back to the very beginning of your book that the whole revelation is about
bringing us back into the order in which we were created. So what he's looking for is seeing how
she is growing towards being fully in the divine will. Okay? Clean of dust of course is clean of
sinfulness. Then he takes my hand and removes the rings which he gave me. Do you remember the rings
back there? When he espoused me to himself, oh sorry, when he espoused me to himself,
you're back in Volume 1. That's Volume 1 when she had her divine marriages. One of them he found
intact and the rest he dostered with his breath. I find that rather interesting. In other words
that the relationship needs to be given a bit of renewing every now and then but anybody who's
ever been in a relationship with anybody knows that has to happen isn't that right? And then he
placed them back. Then it is as if he clothes me completely and then he places himself near and
he says yes you are beautiful but notice that he worked on it first before he said it. Come to me
I cannot be without you. Either you come to me or I come to you. You are my beloved, my joy and my
contentment. Now that's straight out of the song of songs and I don't give you a chapter in verse
because it's repeated frequently. While he says this the light riggles about. Now it's the light
thing they were after and makes every effort for it wants to go to Jesus into Jesus and as it begins
its flight I see the confessor blocks it with his hands and wants to enclose it inside me and
Jesus remains quiet and lets him do it. God what pain. Every time this happens it seems I'm going to
die. Can you see that her soul wants to go back to where it came from? And since he has been working
on it he's happier with it so why couldn't she go back. Every time this happens it seems I'm going
to die and reach the harbor but obedience makes me find myself on the way again. If I wanted to say
everything about this light I would never end. What is so painful for me to write about this that I
can't go on. Also many other things I'm unable to express and therefore I'll keep silent. I should
have to talk about them in the higher volumes. She won't actually be left away with it and so
she will walk back to it. So notice that the image of Jesus she saw Jesus as a light and then she sees
herself as a light and one light needs to be absorbed into the other. Okay so we have to become
like him. I think it's one John three two I think it is. We will be like him when we see him as he
really is. So when the work in us has been completed we're actually like him. So what actually goes to
heaven is what is like God. What cannot enter heaven is what is not like God. Because God can
only make us like himself. He's the only model he's the only image and so he has the Lord has to
work on us and that's why he has to try and get us to get rid of selfishness because that's not like
God. You know what I mean? But it's very interesting to see her own being more and more like Jesus and
completely spiritualized. That's why she sees it as light. Now the reason why the image is light
is because when you go into the higher volumes the divine will is spoken about all the time as light
and we're being absorbed into that light and being made more and more and more spiritual.
And if we reach the deepest depths in the divine will we will be completely spiritualized and therefore
you'll see yourself as you mightn't see yourself but according to this image you would be seen as
light. Does that make sense? So the speck of light going back to the source of light. Okay that makes
sense? Okay so July the 10th 1906 one who gives herself completely to Jesus. Now you see that's the
issue that we're dealing with. It's us giving ourselves completely to him not just giving ourselves
partially because in the early contact with the all this divine will stop you'll be doing acts
in the divine will but that doesn't mean every moment of every day and every moment of every night
is is his. Do you know what I mean? We have an extraordinary ability to keep bits for ourselves.
Absolutely extraordinary. We don't even think about it. We don't even make a decision about it.
That's why there's a lovely thing. I think it's in volume 23 where the Lord says make sure your
emptiness is really empty. Make sure you're nothing this is really empty. And I remember when I read
that we all laughed it's our ability to fill the drawers again. You know what I mean? We gave them
but you know I like this bit. So the one who gives herself completely to Jesus receives the whole
of him. Now the image we've just seen is that the whole of Jesus that image of light you saw it in
Louisa as well. She had given herself completely to him. So as a little light she could go back
to the source. I want to remind you of Teresa Vavala God alone sufficed. And while we know
that we might not actually put it into practice. As I was in my usual state our Lord came for a
short time and told me my daughter one who gives herself completely to me deserves that I give
myself completely to her. Beside that I wanted with John 14 21 you and me and I and you both
completely won. John 14 21 also verse 23. Okay I've said this to you before many times that
when Padre Pia was asked to explain why God had worked so many miracles through him
he answered very simply I deny him nothing and he denies me nothing. So that's that's the complete
giving on both sides. So here I am at your complete disposal whatever you want take it he says.
Now that you're going to hear that that was the relationship that God had with Adam
before the fall that he wanted Adam to take whatever he wanted. And Louisa said I didn't ask him for
anything I only said my good I do not want anything I only want you you alone that she's very very
clear about what she wants and you know you will succeed in life if you're very clear about what you
want. If you're utterly confused about what you want you won't get it simply because you don't
know what you want. You alone are enough for me and everything because if I have you I have
everything and he said brother you asked well and while wanting nothing you have wanted everything
because if you have him you have everything. So I want to give you two Corinthians 6 10
Paul says as having nothing I possess everything two Corinthians 6 10
so what Louisa said to Jesus was I don't want your money I want your bank
very clever move very clever move and of course he got it instantly you want the bank
so July the 12th 1906 everything that serves as sufferings to the creature actually touches God
so having struggled very much and waiting for my blessed Jesus I was feeling tired and exhausted
so most of the messages tonight tell you that Louisa is going through a very very difficult time
then coming almost in passing Jesus told me my daughter everything that serves as sufferings
or as pricking to the creature I love that expression you know the irritations that you know
you say to yourself they're too small to tell anybody but they annoy the heart as me you know
to me he calls them pricking and sometimes he will call them thorns you know they serve us
pricking to the creature on one hand pricks the creature and on the other touches God
God seems to be very very sensitive the suffering of any kind and God feeling touched at each touchy
fields gives always something divine to the creature now what you're being told here is
that no matter what the suffering is physical mental emotional spiritual whether it's caused
by you or anybody else or not that might be sent by God no matter what it is if you're going
through a difficult time that God is extremely sensitive to you and it's terribly important to
keep responding to him okay so july the 17th we're going to get another key all right
to one who does the will of God Jesus gives the key of his treasures
and there is no grace that comes from God in which he doesn't take part
okay so this morning I saw blessed Jesus with a key in his hands and he said to me
my daughter this key is the key of my will
it befits one who lives in my will to have the key in order to open and close as she pleases
that's like giving you the key of the house and to take whatever she likes of my treasures
because that was what he wanted from Adam before the fall in fact by living out of my will
she will look after my treasures more than if they were her own because all that is mine is hers
and she won't spoil them rather she will give them to others or will take for herself for herself
whatever can give me more honor and glory therefore behold I deliver the key to you
look after my treasures now notice if you analyze this
that he will give the key to somebody who knows how to relate to him who will honor his treasures
who will look after his honor and glory and will use them to help others now there's your
substitution reparation for everybody in the in the divine will and that you look out for God's
honor and glory and fill the voids that other people have left because they're not giving him
the honor and glory that's why it's good to take the little paragraph to say now what exactly
my finding here and that's why your study groups have been a great help to get you to analyze a text
so while he was saying this I felt all immersed in the divine will so much so that I could see
nothing but will of God and I spent the whole day in this paradise of his will to see how these
messages all build on one another what happiness and what contentment Louisa said during the night
as I found myself outside of myself I continued to be in this atmosphere that is in the divine will
and the Lord added see my beloved for one who lives in my will there is no grace that comes from my
will for all creatures of heaven and earth which she does not take part in first is that something
else there's nothing that she doesn't participate in first she's she's number one okay that's like
saying I'm a mother and you're all my children I've got this big bag of sweets and I say no you're
first you take your choice you're first so that person is in a very special relationship then
okay while saying this I felt all oh yes there's no grace which comes from my will
for all creatures of heaven and earth that's four legged ten legged a hundred legged two winged
one winged whatever any creature not just human beings in which she doesn't take part first
so you can see that she now fits that Romans 819 she's one of the sons of god
and this is natural because the one who lives in the house of the father is the one who abounds
in everything Romans 8 all over the place okay all the privileges of being in the favor of the Lord
she abounds in everything and if others who are outside receive something it's the surplus
from the one who lives inside see the one who lives inside is the actual child of god the ones
who are outside are either the adoptive children of god who may be doing the will of god but not
living in the will of god or people at a greater distance so she becomes she is the soul becomes
a benefactor to everybody who can say what I understood she keeps on saying that she understands
more than she can deliver that's perfectly normal for somebody coming back from a very spiritual
place and these are things that cannot be expressed that's one Corinthians two nine the things that
god has prepared for us we just can't put words on it one Corinthians two nine okay one Corinthians
two nine do you need the heat put on if you do it's the second button do you see the little panel
there it's the second but just just press it are you all right okay so july the 21st 1906 this is
very important the intention is everything would you give yourself a heading the intention is
everything having come for a little blessed Jesus told me my daughter all human actions even holy
ones done without a special intention for me come out of the soul full of darkness now he didn't say
partial darkness he said full wasn't that frightening so i wanted to put john eight 29 beside that
i only do what pleases him is jesus's intention while if they are done with an upright and special
intention to please me they come out full of light because the intention is the purge of the action
now if i do a very if you look at me for a moment if i do a very simple thing of lifting this
pen up and putting it down i've done an action which is neither good nor bad if i want to make it
a good action i can decide to do that for love of god and saint ray says that the smallest action
even picking a pin off the floor if you do it out of pure love for god is worth all the projects on
the planet okay so i add something to it by adding the intention now sometimes we do good things and
we forget to place the intention and if you read the writings of saint rays all over the place i'm
doing i'm doing this for love of you jesus i'm doing it for love of you and that is the highest
intention so if i want to make this action even greater i'm not only doing it out of love for god
but i'm going to you since i'm now making it an act of love i now united with all the acts of love
in jesus's life and gained his infinite merits now this action is very important okay we're still
not divine now i raise it up onto the divine level i put it into the divine will and it becomes acts
of love forever going to all creatures past present and future and it was such a simple
thing to do so that's the key to real success in divine will every single little thing you're doing
whether you're shifting a cup or anything else it's for love of you united with your acts of love
in the divine will for all can you see i do the divine will and we have those last person future
that's well i brought you on a journey before that because what i did was lodged it in love
first and then i lodged it with the acts of love in jesus's life so it's through him with him and in
him through his humanity through his divinity if you shift to the divinity without adding whether
it's reparation or love or whatever i think you've missed is that okay but at the same time i'm not
a one for all kinds of formula it's just to make sure that you know the intention that this is
either love reparation or whatever just go through that again you do it in love i do it for love of
jesus so the first stage is i do it for love of jesus matter what it is even if it's only
tying the shoelaces and then i united with the acts of love in jesus's life that's number two
with the united with the acts of love in jesus's life to gain his infinite merits
so that the act i'm going to put into the divine will is a very valuable one do you know what i mean
so i do it for love of jesus i united with the acts of love in jesus's life so that again his
infinite merits then lifted up into the divine will so it becomes divine love and not just human
love and it goes on forever is that okay so it becomes divine love and not just human love
and if you want to finish the formula you can say to the lord i want to multiply this to infinity
for an infinitude of time not absolutely necessary but sometimes it helps us to understand what we're
doing is that okay it is into the divine will so it becomes divine love it here becomes divine love
and helps all souls multiply multiply to infinity to infinity forever for all time i just say for
an infinitude of time you multiply it to infinity forever and then i lift it up into the divine will
because i'm lifting up something that is extremely valuable and meritorious
and then multiply it forever and it's it you don't have to say the formula you just have to get the
idea into your head and you know what to do yeah because i i'm not i'm not in favor of formulas but
just to to know the route to go that okay so july the 27th 1906 in the cross jesus
daward souls what a terrible word do you know what daward is he actually gifted us
and espoused them to himself he gifted us okay it's like a dowry do you know what i mean
this morning as my adorable jesus made himself seen embracing the cross i thought in my interior
what were his thoughts in receiving the cross it's luisa's fantastic she'll ask questions that we
want to ask or so what were his thoughts and he said my daughter when i received the cross i
embraced it as my dearest treasure now we're not inclined to do that are we no because in the cross
i endowed souls i think is what we would say there's another language we would use
i endowed or gifted souls and espoused them to myself that's in the cross
now upon looking at the cross at its length and breadth you get this in the
they are the passion as well don't you i rejoiced because i saw in it sufficient dowries now you can
see what he's talking about for all my spouses that's you and me and none of them could fear
not being able to marry me that's actually extremely important because i've met so many
catholics who've said actually i'll get into heaven by the skin of my teeth and i i say to them
that's an insult the lord wants to give you his highest and best i said but i'm a nobody i say
he specializes in nobodies and if you're not a nobody he tells you to become a nobody quick
and get into your nothingness but they're using their i'm not special or i've had trouble in my
life or i've made mistakes in my life or whatever they're using all of that as an excuse not to
come close to the lord and they don't realize that they're their own worst enemy and jesus said
in the cross there's the dowry to make you reach the fullness in divine union it's not fantastic
he said because i held in my own hands in the cross the price of their dowry so he's the bridegroom
and he has the price for the bride for her spiritual wedding that's the language he's using is that
okay but with this conditional loan that if the soul accepts the little gifts i send her
which are the crosses notice the little gifts i think that's brilliant isn't it
and the very things we complain about are the little gifts okay if they would accept the little
gifts which are the crosses as the pledge of her acceptance of me as her spouse the marriage is
formed and i give her the gift of the dowry if then she doesn't accept the gift that is if she's not
resigned to my will everything's undone and even if you if you want to dowry her i've never heard
that word before have you uh i cannot because in order to form a marriage it always takes the will
of both sides my reaction to that is i won't become a pilot because i don't want to be one
does that make sense but i will become a saint if i wanted badly enough
but you won't become a saint if you don't want it badly enough because if you don't want it badly
enough you won't make the sacrifices and you won't accept the cross but if i do want to be a pilot
i'll go to pilot school and i'll do all the training and all the rest of it in other words you have to
accept what goes with becoming a pilot is that okay and jesus says that our will to enter into this
relationship is extremely important and since the soul doesn't accept the gift it means that
she doesn't want to accept the marriage okay it's very interesting there i really examined that
so i'll give you another one uh july the 28th
uh 1906 the daringness of the soul and jesus defends her so continuing my usual state blessed
jesus came for a short time and as soon as i saw him i took him and clasped him in my arms
now notice that louisa is not shy in this relationship uh she's not somebody sort of
who sits there and jesus has to do everything as soon as she sees him she grabs him i think it
is very interesting i think our relationship is brilliant yeah i clasped him in my arms but so
tightly as if i wanted to enclose him in my heart in other words he's talking about absorbing us
into him and you hear me she trying to absorb him into her uh which of course is the instinct of love
isn't it at that moment i saw some people around me saying how daring she is she takes too many
liberties and when one takes liberties it's uh there is not that esteem and respect that one
should have and she doesn't say who's saying this uh i felt all a blush on hearing this she said
but i couldn't do otherwise and the lord said to them it can only be said that one loves
esteem and respects an object when one wants to make it his own okay so there's you have the lover
claiming the beloved okay and when one does not want to make it his own it means that he doesn't
really love it and therefore he has neither esteem nor respect for it for example if one wants to know
whether someone loves riches in speaking to him about riches he holds them in the highest esteem
he respects rich people for nothing else than that they are rich and he would want to make all
riches his own he found the other hand he does not love them he in merely speaking one speak about
them in hearing one speak about them sorry he becomes annoyed and so with all the other things
so rather than blame she deserves praise and if she wants to make me her own it means that she
loves me esteem me and respects me so the lord is saying have energy in your love for him
isn't it lovely yeah but i mean in any kind of espousal relationship if one of the spouses
has no interest and no energy in the thing it kills the dead doesn't it yeah kills it dead
so do you want me to do one more with you i'll do july the 31st 1906 jesus speaks about simplicity
continue in my usual state blessed jesus came for a little and embracing me fully we would say
he told me my daughter simplicity is to virtues what condiment is to food i love that
for a simple soul there are neither keys nor doors to enter into me
that's something terribly important that's like saying he's going to explain i think
that light is very simple so even if you have the blinds down and the sun shines the following
morning the sun will get around the blind it's so simple if you get through the tiniest crevice
and simplicity is the same the opposite of that is complexity and people who want to analyze
everything and parse everything they're the complex ones who the simple one would be a saint before
the others have come to the conclusion that they could make a move and for a simple soul there are
neither keys nor doors to enter into me nor are there for me to enter into her because from all
sides she can enter into me and i to her because it's simple there's no complexity about it even
more to better say it or we would say to say it better she finds herself in me without entering
into me because by her simplicity she comes to resemble me who am most simple spirit now you need
to color that one i am most simple spirit so that's why you can see that Jesus would not get on well
with scribes and Pharisees okay they were anything but simple but he got on awfully well with children
who were simple and with little people who didn't have a complex reaction to him i am most simple
spirit and only because i am most simple i am present everywhere sam 139 where can i go from your
spirit where can i flee from your face if i go to the heavens you are there if i go to the depths of
the sea you are there and so um one three nine so because i am most simple spirit i am present
everywhere and nothing can escape my hand a simple soul is like the light of the sun
now that was the example i gave you a minute ago in spite of any fog or in the fact that the rays
pass through whatever rubbish it remains always light it gives light to all and it never changes
in the same way a simple soul no matter what mortification or displeasure she may receive
does not cease to be light for herself and for those who bought a fighter and if she sees evil
things she does not become stained she remains always light that's that is us transformed utterly
spiritually that the image of light is given nor does she change because simplicity is that virtue
which most resembles the divine being look at that for a statement really needs a bit of color
so the piece of information i have for myself in the margin there is this is the entrance point
okay only through this virtue can one participate in the other divine qualities and only in the soul
who is simple are there no impediments or obstacles for divine grace to enter and operate
in fact since both one and the other are light one light easily unites and transforms into the other
and deweza then says well who can say what i understood about this simplicity i feel as though
a sea is in my mind and i am able to manifest but a few drops of that sea and those disconnected
even among themselves okay before i stop i just wanted to say that when i was reading that the
thing that was uppermost in my mind was the apostle john as the simple one who could get right into
the heart of jesus right from the very beginning and was closest to the heart of jesus all the time
and then you had judas the complex one who just never made it he just couldn't get it he was far
too complex and his soul was too clogged up with all kinds of stuff is that okay so i'll stop this
and we can have a discussion